i
hola muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france 24 soy
santiago ariztía y en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña mónica giraldo ella es
psicóloga y además directora ejecutiva
de la fundación pro derecho a morir
dignamente de colombia junto a ella
vamos a abordar un tema que suele estar
rodeado de tabúes de polémica y que
divide además las opiniones a lo largo
de todo el mundo hablamos de la
eutanasia mónica giraldo muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24
ante algo muchas gracias a ustedes por
la invitación y sobre todo por abrir el
espacio para hablar como lo decías de
temas muy polémicos como la muerte digna
y la otan hacia absolutamente mónica
colombia es uno de los pocos países de
todo el mundo que permite la eutanasia
en américa latina' de hecho es el único
país que permite la muerte asistida bajo
ciertas condiciones cuál es el marco
legal que la permite como es el
procedimiento para acceder a en colombia
a la eutanasia
bueno efectivamente colombia es un país
de hockey avanzada para ser de
latinoamérica y para llevar tanto tiempo
con la eutanasia es penalizada nosotros
desde 1997 llegas es una parte de la
gracias a la sentencia de la corte
constitucional despenalizó leo está
náusea por medio de la figura de
homicidio por piedad
posteriormente en el 2014 y en cuatro
meses finalmente el ministerio de salud
ssa con la resolución que reglamenta el
procedimiento de eutanasia y reglamenta
la conformación de los comités de muerte
digna entonces a partir de ese momento
el 2014 en colombia se comienzan a hacer
procedimientos de auto navia ya bajo la
reglamentación del ministerio de salud
actualmente que está reglamentado a la
otan así en qué casos está reglamentado
primero pues en casos en que hay
pacientes tenga una enfermedad terminal
quien determina si alguien tiene una
enfermedad terminal o no es el médico
atrapa que a partir de los criterios
médicos viendo la publicación del
paciente la respuesta o no respuesta y
tratamiento y las alternativas
terapéuticas
cuál puede ser el pronóstico de vida de
esta persona segundo el segundo
requisito es que la solicitud de
eutanasia la haga la propia persona
entonces ahora puedo hacer en el momento
que me encuentro al final de bien se lo
puedo hacer a mi médico directamente o
lo puedo dejar expresamente dicho por
medio una voluntad anticipada o
anticipada en nuestro país se puede
hacer por medio de delito por medio de
un documento o voluntad anticipada o por
medio de los vídeos si yo no tengo la
capacidad de escribir entonces a partir
de ese marco normativo en colombia como
se puede acceder a la otan hacia una vez
yo sepa que tengo una enfermedad
terminal que no sé tengo un cáncer por
ejemplo tengo un tiempo de proyección de
la enfermedad llevo cinco años el
tratamiento no me está funcionando ya me
enviaron a cuidados paliativos y los
médicos me dicen que ya no hay nada que
hacer y que mi expectativa de vida es
corta y yo digo no que no y yo decido
que no quiero alargar mi sufrimiento
colocar mi agonía pues y desbanca que
quiero aportar la muerte por medio de
out en asia te hago esta solicitud
expresa mi médico y amiguetes que es la
entidad en colombia que brinda los
servicios de salud entonces por medio de
la manifestación de gol
sobre la otan hacia la entidad de salud
en el sistema se debe convocar algo que
se llama el comité de muerte de los
comités de muerte digna viene están
conformados por un especialista en la
misma patología del paciente en este cap
que estamos viendo en este ejemplo sería
por un oncólogo por un psicólogo clínico
por un psiquiatra que va a evaluar el
paciente está tomando la decisión de
manera autónoma libre y totalmente
consciente y por un abogado
este comité se reúne evalúa el caso y
determinar si el paciente cumple o no
con los requisitos para ser aplicada la
eutanasia una vez se dé el visto bueno
pues desde diga si usted cumple con el
requisito se determina la fecha de
aplicación del procedimiento de la mano
del paciente
ahora en muchos países de américa latina
y no solo de esta región en todo el
mundo no se exige la legalización de la
eutanasia y nuestro reclamo nuevo sino
que hace ya muchísimos años que muchas
personas lo vienen viendo en los
proyectos sin embargo no son aprobados
porque cree que casi ningún país lo
permite pareciera estar rodeada de la
eutanasia como de cierto tabú no en el
que se mezclan cuestiones éticas
científicas religiosas legales también
y creo que nosotros y ahora que está
inmersa en un tabú es la muerte per se
normalmente vemos la muerte de como el
coco el sistema y que normal no
hablábamos cuando en realidad creo que
hasta ahora ninguna de nosotros es
inmortal o si alguien que nos está
viendo es inmortal que nos cuenta la
fórmula pero hasta el momento todos
sabemos que en algún momento de la vida
en algún transformará bien nuestro
cuerpo programa pero se va a morir y en
este orden de ideas pues hay que
comenzar a hablar de la muerte a parte
ok a partir de ahí si yo me voy a morir
pues yo también debo decidir en este
orden de que tengo derecho a tener una
vida digna pues también como quiero
llegar a ese final de mi vida y aparte y
plantearme desde ahí como quiero tener
para mí una muerte digna y poder abrirle
entonces el campo las diferentes
opciones de muerte digna
dónde están si bien los cuidados
paliativos adecuará el esfuerzo
terapéutico
también estarán tan asia es decir
poderme adelantar mi muerte para no
prolongar la agonía o el sufrimiento
porque es un tabú porque pensamos que es
un crimen porque pensamos que estamos
de otra persona y seguramente ahí entran
muchas discusiones políticas muchas
discusiones religiosas muchas
discusiones de fe pero realmente cuando
un paciente está el final de la vida y
está con un gran sufrimiento y es su
voluntad la eutanasia pues se convierte
en un acto de compasión por las personas
pero yo siento que el debate no lo
deberíamos llevar a ver si está bien no
está mal sino que educación estamos nos
estamos dando como sociedad y qué
conversaciones nos estamos permitiendo
tener qué tan abiertos somos esas
conversaciones complicadas que si bien
no queremos enfrentar la vida nos va a
obligar a hacerlo entonces ojalá los
países se que varios países perú está
teniendo estas discusiones en este
momento argentina-chile por tu en
portugal en españa que bueno que se
puedan tener las conversaciones y que
ampliamos el panorama legalizar la
eutanasia no significa que todo el mundo
entonces ahora opta por la otan hacia
nuestro país desde 2014
y se han realizado más o menos 94
procedimientos de muerte digna' 40 nació
entonces no es que sea un número muy
elevado sino que al contrario le estamos
dando una mácula diferentes alternativas
son mayor opción al paciente para que
pueda tomar decisiones informadas
conscientes y libres y sobre todo que
vayan de acuerdo con sus valores y sus
creencias
mónica de recién mencionaba usted de un
tema justamente sobre que le quería
preguntar que tiene que ver con la
muerte no uno de los grandes temas
existenciales no incluso la única
certeza que tenemos a lo largo de
nuestra vida y sin embargo un tema que
nos genera angustias temores muchísimos
miedos es necesario repensar la muerte
resignificar la
pues yo creo que te robaste mis palabras
normalmente yo creo que estás muy
amabilidad y es una de las razones por
las que decidí trabajar en este tema y
es porque siento que todos deberíamos
repensar nos da muerte y resignificado a
muerte yo siento que lo vemos como el
coco como que nos va a quitar pues como
el final de algo pero al final la muerte
puede ser para quien se está muriendo la
graduación de una vida bien vivida y
para quienes estamos acompañando a morir
al ser herido puede ser una de las
lecciones más valiosos del mundo es
decir la muerte nos permite entre
aprender a vivir desde el día a día si
yo soy consciente que algún día me voy a
morir que yo soy consciente que de algún
día ya no voy a estar pues voy a hacer
hasta lo imposible para disfrutar cada
día de mi vida y eso es una de las cosas
que a mí me ha enseñado la muerte es
aprender a vivir conscientemente
aprender a disfrutar y hacer lo que
quiero
entonces no significa que porque yo abre
la muerte ya me quiera morir pues no al
contrario yo descubierto que la tienes
hablamos de la muerte
más vivir disfrutamos cada día nos
disfrutamos reírnos y tener estas
conversaciones esta invitación es a
talcual repensemos nos da muerte y
comencemos a generar espacios de diálogo
y conversación donde hablar de la muerte
sea una excusa para disfrutar la vida
usted se va años mónica acompañando a
pacientes oncológicos también a sus
familiares que aprendizajes que
enseñanzas y reflexiones le ha dejado
toda esta experiencia
yo creo que el principal aprendizaje y
enseñanzas que cada historia es única
cuando uno acompaña al final de la vida
no hay ninguna historia igual al otra y
por eso es tan importante que nunca
comparemos las experiencias de una
persona o de un familiar o de un cercano
con el de otro y es la segunda gran
reflexión o experiencia que a mí me
queda y que la vivida en carne propia la
importancia hablar eso en el hogar
porque vivir la muerte acompañado de la
familia y cuando hemos tenido estas
conversaciones incómodas termina siendo
un acto mucho más bonito más bondadoso
más empático que cuando eso no se ha
hablado y el final de la vida se vuelve
como en una negación y se sufre
muchísimo más entonces como las dos
grandes lecciones es uno hablarlo y dos
a vivirlo como si fuera una experiencia
única cada muerte y acá acompañamiento
tras sus lesiones propias y seguramente
a cada uno le deja una de enseñanzas
únicas que va a poder aplicar en el
resto
un poco ya adelantada respecto de esto
[__] pero usted ha dicho en alguna
oportunidad que la muerte es la
experiencia más enriquecedora de la vida
podría desarrollar esta idea por favor
totalmente y no sé qué tan vario sea en
este espacio o en esta entrevista pero
yo llegué a hablar de la muerte por una
experiencia propia y ahí es cuando digo
para mí fue la experiencia más
enriquecedora de la vida yo llegué a
hablar de la muerte porque hace más de
16 años mi papá se suicidó y cuando él
se suicidó y decidió optar por el
suicidio como una muerte en mi caso esto
era un tema tabú y nadie lo hablaba y
entonces como nadie hablaba de la muerte
pues yo no tuve tiempo no tuve forma de
elaborar un duelo y no tuve forma de más
despedirme a mi papá yo acá no estoy
juzgando si su decisión fue bueno fue
mala si fuera correcta era incorrecta
pero si bien y aprendí en ese momento
que si la muerte hubiera sido un tema de
conversación en mi casa seguramente la
historia se hubiera desarrollado
diferente y yo me hubiera podido
despedir
a partir de esa experiencia de vida y a
partir de esa elaboración de bueno me di
cuenta la capacidad de resiliencia que
yo tenía que tenemos los seres humanos
para levantarnos de las situaciones
difíciles y para de nuevo resignificar
esas experiencias dolorosas y comenzar a
poner un color diferente y me di cuenta
que mi experiencia personal la muerte
era la experiencia o la lección de vida
más enriquecedora y que más me
fortalecía y es por eso que trabajo en
esto y me doy cuenta en el día a día
claro la muerte no es color de rosa y
también lo vivo con las personas que
acompañan no todas las muertes o no
todas las personas en un proceso del
duelo lo hagan resignificar el oiga
sacar esa habilidad de resiliencia tan
fácilmente o después de un poco más pero
volvemos a lo mismo cada caso es único
pero seguramente todos de la muerte
vamos a poder aprender algo hay
despedirnos de kim que tenemos
y el despedirnos incluso de nosotros
mismos
mónica giraldo muchísimas gracias por su
presencia la entrevista de france 24 ha
sido realmente un placer dialogar con
usted
no a usted santiago por la invitación y
ustedes por escucharnos y por siempre
abriendo hacer espacio muchísimas
gracias a nuestra ciencia como siempre
le invitamos a continuar informándose en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]
y